tonight some thoughts on this eve of
Thanksgiving it's supposed to be a
holiday dedicated to our families our
friends and the ties that bind it's a
holiday where gratitude should above all
else be placed front and center but the
reality is that in recent years it's
become something far different a holiday
that's been tarnished by never-ending
sales on flat-screen tvs appliances all
manner of jewelry
forcing folks to spend time waiting in
line sometimes for days instead of
cherishing the time they have with their
families polling shows that the majority
of Americans say they're gonna shop
online this holiday season with internet
sales poised to surpass 100 billion
dollars for the first time ever sure
that's good for the economy no doubt but
shouldn't we just dedicate one day one
day to family and giving thanks without
having to buy anything just take a look
at how early these sales start this week
Kohl's they kicked off at turkey day
discounts on Monday Old Navy
knocking 50% off all items beginning
today and by the time Thanksgiving
morning rolls around virtually every
major retailer will be back
offering Black Friday deals that will
bring folks to the store or to their
computers before they even have time to
prep their meal let alone clean it up
and that leads me to my next point
why are stores even open on Thanksgiving
at all
I know retailers they need to sell and I
get it they make all their money this
time of year it's the biggest season of
the year for them but is it worth the
breaking up of families on the one day
that some of them spend time together
that one day a year it's bad enough that
consumers are dragged away from their
families but what about the employees
who are forced to staff the stores just
look at this partial lift list of stores
open tomorrow
Kmart is one of the first to open
cracking its doors at 6 a.m.
Dollar General Bass Pro Shops I love
Bass Pro Shops I love Cabela's but
they're not far behind and by the end of
the day they'll be joined by JC Penney
Old Navy Walmart Target
many others oh I worry then in our haste
to buy for everyone on our list it's
going to cause our relationships to fray
with the people we love the most and
some things are worth more than 100
bucks you might save on that wide screen
and in most cases those doorbuster sales
are come on to get your device some
other junk you don't need anyway how
many times have you stood in line for
that $200 iPad on Black Friday only to
learn that the sale only applied to the
first 5 sold and turns out you're the
38th person in line read the fine print
before you give up the stuff that really
matters the stuff that you're never
going to get back and then won't ever go
on sale
that's time with friends and family and
part of what drives us into the cold it
makes us want to join those Black Friday
blowouts and the Friday mobs is the
thought that we might miss out on a
great opportunity my goodness we got to
get there we got to drive that we're
gonna park there but on Thanksgiving the
biggest opportunity in the world is back
home and it's around the table so savor
this Thanksgiving try to celebrate it
without wrestling your neighbors over a
Salesman